[Music]
and got played Muse submitted by OC
greater than la na she got Disneyland
what else
Elsie's nice don't they have like really
clean streets and [ __ ] ever
big wide streets and beaches and not a
beach and stuff whatever it's like the
best Vietnamese food and stuff whatever
whatever a man scammed investors out of
14 million dollars with the fake Netflix
film deal oh no point two million think
you're the same number happen we can't
even get one [ __ ] movie deal and this
guy [ __ ] stabbed
that's all I'm like we need a scam for
some money guys his name is Adam Joyner
41 years old
sounds like a liar ready he lives in
Manhattan Beach Oh Oh see no that's
actually by the South Bay
Oh Santa keeps feeding into the thing
okay so he was expressed expected to
make his his debut or not debut but like
a movie from his production company
called dark planet planet
pictures dark planet pictures whoo
that's a cool logo that is people this
is his house by the way ooh
on the beach in Manhattan Beach that's
like a millions of dollars so he ended
up receiving money for this project that
he was calling legends which was
described as an anachronistic mash-up of
legendary and historical figures from
19th century America such as Davy
Crockett colada me Jane Paul Bunyan and
John Henry oh cool so that's what that
movie was supposed to be and he said he
even provided a script and said that his
brother wrote it so he defrauded Korea
investment global contents fund a South
Korea investment fund who's managed by
Korean partners and also by Chinese a
Chinese investment firm and caught in
all these Asians we need to know their
contacts we can con them too
will actually make yeah we're actually
gonna make it
so this this all began in late 2015 when
he met the director of one of the of the
Korea Investment Partners company and
that's when he gave him the script and
that's when the the Korean investment
firm decided to give or to invest eight
million dollars in the project and then
in April 2016
he ended up transferring they ended up
transferring the first half of the
investment to dark planet pictures can
you imagine just having four million
just in your account overnight like that
oh no I don't know what that feels like
what would you do I'd run with the money
for millions a lot of money you're
tripping it's not as much kidding I
probably run with it and go oh wait I
stood back there's four more left oh I
got to go back and pretend more before
they transfer that four million he
provided a false distribution form yeah
saying that a Netflix executive signed
it and but it was all falsified and
that's why they believed him and gave
him the four million yeah but he kept
this up because he was able to do the
Chinese firms from four six million yeah
in June of 2016 by providing the same
bogus Netflix distribution agreement and
then he ended up receiving the initial
ten million from the investors what a
great producer it could have actually
got this mean yeah exactly so then
that's when he said yes [ __ ] that
well-known figures such as producer Don
Murphy who has worked on and we rush I'm
blinking on his projects it was in the
other article the goofy movie oh my god
I'll tell a ticket pen yeah like so he
was able he said that he got producer
Don Murphy to work on it
[Laughter]
you worked on transformers transformers
last night bumblebee okay a lot of
Transformers that's big yeah so and so
he said that that producer was there but
then the Don Murphy ended up failing cuz
he was like there's nothing happening in
this project like there's no director
there's nothing like for him to want to
stay so he ended up bailing out and then
he told the investors that his job to
make something happen if he's a producer
no there's like different types of
producers I was like the ones that are
providing financial that's executive
producing and then there's like
producers that are like making things
representation yeah like mm-hmm
finding locations alone yeah they're
saying that no distributor was
identified no talent was secured and no
director was committed to the film so
then that's when he terminated his
arrangement in mid 2017 and then that's
in late 2016 that's when this dude told
his investors that he terminated the
distribution agreement with Netflix and
secured a new agreement with
ambling partners which was also fake and
that's when they gave him another form
oh my god yeah in early 2017 why would
they need to give him another four
million maybe I used to finish
production and they keep he keeps
sending them like he could be like yeah
we need more yeah you just kept giving
these investors all these excuses as to
saying like why the project was not
moving forward and provided porridge
baek's forged bank statements to South
Korean investors to prove that he could
repay their investment wrong but then
that's when FBI reviewed the bank
records and determined that more than
five million of that money was used to
purchase a Manhattan home and another
4.3 million was transferred to a bank
account that may be linked to another
film that he's working on no yeah this
dude he faces maximum sentence of 20
years in federal for the wire fraud
charges Monday
money laundering offense
to lead a sentence of up to 10 years and
then the aggravated identity theft
charge is a two-year mandatory two-year
prison term no but what's crazy is that
even though like when people get charged
like oh you have to owe this much they
could just never pay it if they don't
have the money yeah yeah so those
investors might not ever get their money
back I don't think they will at this
point what he is gonna try something
so they couldn't even sell the house
they'll get that back and they have 4
million in one account that's like 3
million for that house it was fine yeah
maybe for always I've gained 5 so they
get back like 9 million and then he
spent the rest on booze into a pattern
yeah wow that producer to Natural Born
Killers he produced how do you with the
balls to pull off these kind of scams
right look what I was like catch me if
you can I'm like how do you get the
balls like I'm gonna get good at mafia I
know but then you also have to not be
very empathy like towards people that's
what always [ __ ] me is like if I start
getting in bethey towards people then it
like I can't even keep I can't help you
yeah I can't do it yeah help me yeah so
you got to make the people that you're
scamming an enemy I don't want to scam
anybody that's my problem
well I think what happens in these guys
minds is that well first off they're
probably justified in there they're
sociopaths right so they don't have any
guilt a lot of the time so you're saying
you can will yourself into sociopath
land I think you could get there if you
know if you try really hoping trainings
your house okay but if you think about
people who do bad things right they
don't think they're being bad yeah yeah
ever they're able to justify it oh yeah
like recently I was listening to this
book and then they're saying that um who
is a the number one most wanted criminal
in like okay whatever this really famous
dude I forgot it that Bundy no no this
is like way back in like Western times
um
so Billy the Kid no not Billy the Kid
another one doc holliday Dillinger oh
yeah so thank you too far better with
the lady kids so so then um so this guy
that was that's not even Western is it
John Dillinger no there's cars and stuff
okay my bad but the point is that this
book is saying that every person is
driven by the the need to feel important
and they have their own yeah your
character everyone's a hero and their
story your character is shown by the the
way you choose to feel important so John
Dillinger felt important by saying that
he has killed people and that he was
like the enemy number one and that's his
importance and so that's the same thing
what you're saying so these criminals
like they find the the justification for
doing what they're doing because that's
how they feel important
yeah I mean like think about terrorists
right they're not they don't think
they're doing anything bad yeah you
think like they're serving the greater
good yeah they're like oh my god wants
me to do this and then on top of that
you know America like has been bombing
our country for so long they're like
it's payback time
yeah so it's the same [ __ ] and I think
scam artists and all them like they
develop this mentality as if like
they're the heroes and they're also like
an acting you learn all that like you
know it's meta justify and all that
stuff but I'm just saying in real life
yeah I don't know how people get the
balls huh what do you maybe steps yeah
right so like it really is a gateway
like I've went as far as to burglarizing
homes there's no guilt right but it yeah
I mean but it there was it developed it
like the like so I got first you had
some guilt and then it don't first you
steal things and you just keep going and
then you steal cars and you do things
out of cars and then yeah and then
you're also in a world where you're
around people that are doing the same
heists and same things so you're not in
the you're in a bubble so no one's
telling you that I see or you know it's
wrong but you also go you know what's
also wrong is they're born rich and
they're they don't know what it's like
to be me yeah more like you justify
these weird things Oh mal and then later
in life I look back and I'm like that
was a horrible thing to do but in the
moment though I'm like I'm getting
what's mine because [ __ ] society if the
society is not fair mmm-hmm you know oh
yeah and I think that's the same way
with like people that do armed robberies
and same thing it's like oh these guys
could afford it they have jobs they're
rich they came from good homes
like me I came from a [ __ ] up place so
I gotta get what's this kind of thing
we're like you know the movies never
getting made like what's your long-term
planning man I feel what if what if this
idiot was really trying to get something
made and he just [ __ ] up well I mean
why would he fake documents and for like
he's good at getting money but she's end
up getting arrested trying to extend the
whole process I think and eventually
he'll blow it off um three movies down
I'll pay for the first help that the
movies I'll pay for the second movie and
he's just trying to get himself that he
was gonna make it and I know I love
movies like that too though like when
you follow these like crazy cons that
are like it's like I don't glorify it
but then for me I'm like how do you even
get there because everyone starts off
this like baby right with nothing like
it's an empty computer and then they
turn into this yeah so it's like the
cash man if you can story because he
like passed a bar exams he was a doctor
like compile it by yeah use flying
planes he passed the bar yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]